i find that a lot of life coaches so
worry about pro and i'm empathetic to
this they so worry about their financial
situation their selfish things that they
actually do a poor job of trying to
solve everything because they want the
person to continue to pay them and
instead what they should do is actually
fix the problem have somebody's life get
way better that they don't need you
anymore and let that build your business
not let me hold on to that person a
little longer i think that a lot of life
coaches fall into a very dangerous trap
of solving their life not their client's
life and i think that's why a lot of
them stay small i think the way to get
big is solve people's problems so that
they go on and live life they meet up
with their cousin and they're like whoa
why are you so happy while i've been
working with this life coach i don't
work with them anymore because i'm good
all of a sudden that word of mouth leads
to another customer versus retention
and not fully solving someone's problem